this is Jocko podcast number 227 with
echo Charles and me Jacque are willing
good evening echo good evening and
joining us tonight as well is Dave Burke
good evening Dave good evening hmm Marv
admin 2 to 420 subject availability of
MC dp7 learning one purpose the
commanding general training and
education command has published Marine
Corps doctrinal publication 7 learning
dated 20 February 20 20 pound the
Commandant's planning guidance released
17 july 2019 establishing learning a
combination of education and training as
a priority focus area to develop an
intellectual edge to capitalize on the
unique ethos of the Corps and its
maneuver warfare mindset on 20 February
2020 the Commandant of the Marine Corps
General David H burger approved MC dp7
learning the first entirely new
doctrinal publication released by the
Marine Corps since 2001 MC dp7
learning formalizes the philosophy
principles concepts and expectations of
learning MC bp7
learning states that the Marine Corps
learning philosophy seeks to create a
culture of continuous learning and
professional competence that yields
adaptive leaders capable of successful
successfully conducting maneuver warfare
and complex uncertain and chaotic
environments MC dp7 learning has been
developed to codify the Marine course
learning philosophy and explain why
learning is essential to the profession
of arms going forward
MC dp7 learning will serve as a guide
for a culture of continuous learning and
professional competence that yields
adaptive leaders who can quickly wreck
nice changing conditions in the
battlespace adapt and make timely
decisions against a thinking enemy this
publications audience is all Marines
coordinating instructions and initial
distribution of eleven thousand three
hundred and thirty publication hard
copies is underway units requiring
additional print allocations must follow
procedures identified in reference a
paragraph for a this Mar admin is
applicable to Marine Corps for total
force so there you go
the Marine Corps in case you didn't
gather from that message has a new
doctrinal publication the first one
since 2001 and there was probably not
too many people that were a little bit
giddy and excited about it besides
myself and David R Burke proof the
release of this publication in its own
right is proof that the Marine Corps is
learning that's like that's a that's a
bold statement
so yeah the Marine Corps has a new pub
out and we're gonna pour it a study it
right now
so here we go Marine Corps doctrinal
publication seven it's called learning
here we go and we'll start off with the
forward Department of the Navy
headquarters United States Marine Corps
the purpose of this publication is to
describe the Marine Corps as learning
philosophy and explain why learning is
critically important to the profession
of arms while the concept while many of
the concepts in this publication have
been passed on by marine leaders
throughout our history this publication
seeks to formalize them and provide
aspirational goals that's a familiar
subject learning is an institutional
priority and a professional expectation
for all Marines this mentality is key to
the marine corps becoming a more
effective learning organization now
you're gonna find as we run through this
and the way they define learning and the
way they talk about learning obviously
this doesn't only
apply to the profession of arms and it
obviously doesn't apply only to the
Marine Corps it applies to everybody in
the world every human being
continuing on the most important factor
in this philosophy is the importance of
continuous learning throughout our
careers for warfighting
continuous learning is essential to
maneuver warfare because it enables
Marines to quickly recognize changing
conditions in the battle space adapt and
make timely decisions against a thinking
enemy these skills required in war must
be learned developed and honed over time
if neglected they quickly atrophy and
this is one of the first things I notice
is they break down this thing of when
you're on the battlefield and this is so
clear but we're on the battlefield the
enemy's doing something they're changing
their tactics and we've talked about
that for years what you're actually
doing is you're learning what they're
doing and you're learning how you need
to respond to it so the mindset of
learning is that we can we talk about
adaptation a lot well if you can't learn
you're not gonna be able to adapt to
anything Marines leverage the art and
science of learning technologies and
learning environments that reflect the
changing operational environment to
tailor learning and provide each other
with constructive feedback leaders hold
Marines to high professional standards
of performance conduct and discipline to
include learning as Marines rise in rank
and position continuous learning and
development and developing our
professional skills are a professional
expectation so you are that's what it is
if you're in the Marine Corps you're
learning that's the expectation we must
make the most of every learning
opportunity fostering our subordinates
learning while continuing our own
continuous learning is important to
Marines because of the fundamental
nature of war and its ever-changing
character the nature of war carries a
combination of fear uncertainty
ambiguity ambiguity chance horror and
above all friction that Marines must
prepare to counter Marines must seek out
education and training opportunities
that stimulate these conditions
we must train how we fight as Marines we
must understand how important learning
is and be committed to the principles
laid out in this publication our
professional responsibilities as Marines
is to engage in continuous learning so
that we may best support our fellow
Marines our core and our nation signed D
H Berger general u.s. Marine Corps
commandant of the marine corps so that's
how they kick it off and if you haven't
heard Dave and I talk talking about any
of these other any of the other Marine
Corps manuals that we've covered and one
of the very first things that I covered
on this podcast was a war fighting which
is a great publication but the Marine
Corps has a way of writing publications
and a way of writing that is awesome
they nail it alright
so chapter one is called the nature of
learning starts off with some quotes
quotes here as a life switch which I
really don't like general I generally
don't like when things start with quotes
but I think the Marine Corps gets a pass
here you know I generally don't like
when people say even you know you'll
hear someone give us a speech you know
commencement address and they'll say in
the words of so-and-so and you're like
right you know like they could have read
that they're there if you got asked to
do a graduate a commencement speech or
you got asked to give a talk they're
asking you to give that talk right right
am I wrong no you're right and look I'm
not saying that there's not times where
quotes are needed I've used them I don't
use them a lot though I will say that in
fact I rarely use them it's gonna be
probably patent or Hackworth what you're
shaking your head I was gonna say is
it's al gray and Jim mattis yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's but that's kind of my
threshold as well yeah yeah okay yeah
yeah yeah you're gonna go with the first
one as a life time cereal learner I
found that extraordinary people can do
the extraordinary who are committed to
experiential learning are intellectually
curious and possess an unquenchable
desire to acquire new knowledge
this may be our only advantage in the
future fight and that's from Lorna M I
don't know how you say that last name a
lock I guess but she's a general Marine
Corps from Brooklyn New York via Jamaica
but what I like about that is this may
be our only advantage in future fight
because at some point the BLET the
playing fields given level and then it's
who is smarter who it's not even who is
smarter
it's who can learn faster yeah al Gray
29th common out of the Marine Corps two
Purple Hearts Mustang by the way Kami's
by the way if you go and look at all the
Marine Corps commandant SAR all their
dress blues except for one al gray he's
in his cam he's getting after it and he
says what you did isn't as important as
what you were thinking and how many
times when I was in charge of training I
watched somebody do something watch some
young junior officer do something and I
and I look I saw what they did and I'd
say well you know what were you thinking
when you just did that what was your
what was in your head what were you
trying to make happen well I get it I
get what you did I'm not even concerned
about that I want to know what you were
thinking cuz you might have made a you
might have made a bad decision you might
have made a bad tactical call but if you
had a good idea then we can figure out
how to teach you the tactics of getting
it done but if you were thinking
something wrong where we have a bit much
bigger problem and then general mattis
the most important six inches on the
battlefield is between your ears
indeed needs no explanation okay here we
go getting into it war fighting is the
most complex challenging violent and
dynamic human invent endeavor the Marine
Corps as the nation's force and
readiness must have the versatility and
flexibility to effectively fight and
succeed in any situation and at any
intensity across the full spectrum of
conflict whenever and wherever the
nation calls
if you think about what that sentence
says check it out must have the
versatility versatility and flexibility
to effectively fight and succeed in any
situation and this is the part that I
think is really stands out
and at any intensity right this is from
hand-to-hand bloodbath combat to
noncombatant evacuation right this is
just you got to be able to do anything
in the full spectrum continuing to meet
these demands it is critical that
Marines recognize that learning has a
direct impact on war fighting Marines
who understand the key learning
principles and continuously seek
opportunities to develop new knowledge
skills and the proper attitudes
throughout their careers will develop
wisdom that enables success in battle as
Marines we pass on our wisdom and our
experiences to the next generation of
Marines for the Marine Corps to remain
the United States the United States
force in readiness it is critical that
every Marines strengthen and value
learning in all facets of the marine
corps culture learning environments and
leadership development learning is a
professional responsibility for all
Marines at all levels learning is a
Marines and all levels Marines must
develop the habit of continuous learning
early in their careers to set conditions
for success in increasing levels of
responsibility really makes it pretty
clear that's what the Marine Corps yeah
the Marine Corps docks man they nail it
you talk about simple clear and concise
calm yes they just they got it the clear
man it's right there hey we're gonna win
wars we got to get smart what's what I
find most or one of the most impressive
things about when you read this is when
you read really any of the Marine Corps
Doc's pubs a general
a colonel a Gunny sergeant and a lance
corporal yeah can all read this and go
okay I get that yep and I see it right
that's what they do so well it's just
they nail it and the way they do that is
simple clear and concise first section
learning and competence learning is
developing knowledge skills and
attitudes through study experience or
instruction it is a never ending
progression that includes understanding
why something is important the intent of
learning hmm what do you think it's like
okay cool so everything that we talked
about from a decentralized command
perspective when you apply that on an
individual level for learning the exact
same rules apply which means it is your
team has to understand why they're doing
what they're doing in this case people
have to understand why something is
important what do you have to understand
and decentralized command what's the
commander's intent what you have to
understand here is what is the intent of
the learning that goes on learning is
much more than gathering information or
reciting facts it includes cognitive
physical social emotional ethical and
cultural components learning occurs in
formal settings like schoolhouse or
training exercise and in formal settings
such as social experience self directed
and other ways outside of the class
classroom the developing knowledge
skills and attitudes interact to
influence how Marines think respond and
act isn't it weird to think about every
single thing that you do is based on
what you've learned now you could take
the Sam Harris approach here and say
that you have know what freewill
yes
and then you'd have to say okay well if
you want to take that into the
philosophical world Sam we get it I'm
not here to argue philosophy with Sam
Harris what I am gonna tell you is this
when I would see young leaders make
decisions they were making decisions
based on what they learned what they
experienced that's where it all comes
from learning encompasses both training
and education which are equally
important and complimentary a simple
explanations of the difference between
training and education is that training
prepares Marines to deal with known
factors of war while education prepares
Marines to deal with unknown factors
it's an interesting bifurcation of those
two things I'm gonna it's gonna take me
a little while to get my head around
that because I know a lot of the
training that I ran the purpose of the
training was to get seals to learn how
to deal with unknown factors so we may
have to explore that one a little bit I
don't think they're mutually exclusive
but they are different yeah well maybe
we'll have to explore what what they see
as training and what they see as
education you get there this is when I
read this I wasn't I just I underlined
unknown factors and I was like yeah of
course unknown factors that's what we're
trying to teach teach people how to deal
with unknown factors training I guess I
guess where they draw the line is like
hey here's here's the here's the
procedures that we can teach you right
that's your training learn this
procedure I learned this procedure to
learn this procedure education is how do
you take those procedures that you've
learned and adapt them to this random
new thing that you haven't seen before
it's understandable all right I'll begin
to wield my yield I'll begin to yield to
this to this thought process here
training and education are both
accomplished in different ways but they
are required working together to instill
the learning that results in readiness
and effectiveness the complexity of the
modern battlefield an increasing rate of
change requires a highly educated force
while different education and training
are inextricably linked education
denotes study and intellectual
development training is primarily
learning by doing okay so now that
they're laying it out a little education
notes study and intellectual development
training is primarily learning by doing
mmm okay we will we will not train
without the presence of Education and we
must not educate without the
complimentary execution of well
conceived training okay III see you
where they're going I'm not sure that I
would have I'm not sure that I would
have presented this the same way I'm
gonna have I would have to think about
this because training is learning by
doing okay I get it you're hands-on
you're making stuff happen and education
is not right education is is study and
intellectual development that's that's
what they're saying here okay okay I
think I think I'm starting to grasp it a
little bit better because he and here's
how I just grasped it in my mind the
mission of both these things is to learn
mm-hmm right and both of them result in
learning and so in my mind I was
thinking well one is the one you learn
and one you don't learn but the actual
fact is both these things you're gonna
learn it's just a method of learning one
of them is one of them is study and one
of them is doing yeah it almost seems
like it's small things but but I don't
think it's not I mean it's a big thing
to understand the difference between
those two is that if you were just
training all the time and never really
getting an education on what you're
doing or studying or or learning the
bigger picture that that training
wouldn't be nearly as useful you
wouldn't learn as much if you weren't
educating yourself while you're doing I
know they talk more about
but there's this idea like if I'm gonna
go to the rifle range and get really
good at shooting the rifle like a train
on the rifle over and over and over
again I could sit do the same thing in
airplane I could train or over again but
ocation
what the aircraft that I'm fighting
against could do what my enemies capable
of what the 3d environment might be and
that training evolves because of the
education and if all I ever did was sort
of think about what that looked like in
three-dimensional battle space and never
train for it that education by itself I
wouldn't learn as much about doing the
training with it yeah yeah no I yep I'm
seeing it I'm seeing it continuing on
Marines must always seek better ways to
learn throughout the entire continuum of
the training of training and education
throughout this publication the term
learning is emphasized training and
education are you specifically referring
to one or the other learning is the
overall intended outcome of both
training and education so there you go
interestingly that must have that must
have been a little clogged thing in my
brain from when I read this Marines
continuously learned to be ready for the
constantly changing and increasing
demands of warfare and the range of
missions as marine corps doctrinal
publications six command and control
explains we earn the trust of others by
demonstrating competence a sense of
responsibility loyalty and
self-discipline we just talked about
that on the last podcast right the
number one way to to earn trust is
confidence be doing your job think about
that we are in the trust of others by
our own self-discipline
competence is having sufficient
knowledge judgment and skills to perform
a particular duty job or function
Marines improve competencies through
formal and informal learning
opportunities that develop the required
knowledge skills and attitudes Marines
learn to address complex problems and
develop teamwork wherever they may be
whether in garrison deployed or informal
formal learning centers learning enables
Marines to think critically develop
judgment and cultivate a bias for action
without waiting to be told what to do
the perp learning enables Marines to
think critically developed judgment and
cultivate a bias for action without
waiting to be told what to do that is
such the opposite of what people think
that the military is you they everyone
thinks this be told what to do and here
they're the actual words are don't wait
to be told what to do those the actual
words a bias for action a Marine with
knowledge and skills who lacks judgment
requires close supervision which may not
be possible in combat conditions hence
decentralized command one our Marine
Corps Athens ethos demands competence
responsibility loyalty and
self-discipline as military
professionals charged with defense of
the nation learning prepares Marines to
exercise initiative within the
commander's intent constantly seeking to
improve developmental agility and deal
with changing situations whoever was the
guy writing this went out of his way to
not just say discipline because I think
military that's actually not what it is
it's that's that's that by itself is not
enough yep he's he's making it perfectly
clear to everyone that we're not going
to impose discipline on you you need
self-discipline yeah that's what you
need decentralized command
next section the role of learning in war
fighting maneuver warfare requires
intelligent leaders at all levels who
possess a bias for intelligent action Oh
a just through a little change after
yeah intelligent actions not just action
because we don't want you just to take
action once you do something smart
success in land warfare depends on
Marines developing an intellectual edge
to accurately recognize cues make sense
of the information and respond
effectively this intelligent into
intellectual edge is based on developed
knowledge and experience that allows
Marines to shape conditions and events
to their advantage
developing fundamental cognitive
competencies such as problem framing
mental imaging critical thinking
analysis synthesis reasoning and
problem-solving enables Marines to make
effective decisions more quickly in time
constrained operational environments
when they often have incomplete
inaccurate or even contradictory
information there you go
and this is one of those when I was
reading this sentence yesterday you are
editing some of my work the maybe a
couple weeks ago and you said hey you
know this sentence that you wrote here a
lot in here used a lot of words here mmm
think about it
maybe you could tighten this up and I
read it and I was like yeah I'm not
tight in there I said you remember that
one sentence you said yeah and I said I
said I'm not even I'm not changing it
and when I read this sentence I thought
about that I was like well could we have
kind of made this a little bit more
concise but then I read it again I
thought to myself know this every one of
the what would you take out yeah what do
you take out we're gonna take out where
you don't lose some level of meaning and
you know this this kind of sentence
right here you know if you're a young
marine out there that's that's reading
this for the first time you're going
wait a second I mean you know they
didn't cover this and in in you know
junior junior high school English right
so you have to break it down a little
bit you have to go what are they talking
about develop developing fundamental
cognitive competencies okay what does
that mean that means I I need to be able
to think about these things okay what I
need to be able to think about I need
think about problem framing what does
that mean it means assessing looking at
things in a certain way mental imaging
okay what do I see in those things
critical thinking all right now I need
to think about them I need to analyze
those things I need to synthesize need
to take all those things and put them
together I need to reason through them
and then I need to problem-solve yeah so
there's a lot going on there yeah and
those are just synonyms to just repeat
yourself those are different things yeah
and I was I wrote I got notes all
throughout this thing but obviously the
Marine Corps the title of this session
is the role of learning and warfighting
well that's that's cool because this is
the Marine Corps we're about war
fighting if you take out the word marine
and take out the word war fighting this
is describing life you want to talk
about how is this applicable to my world
I have to make decisions when I don't
have when I have incomplete inaccurate
or contradictory information when don't
you have that war fighting it's a
no-brainer but it's actually true
everywhere I mean that this thing is
it's written so clearly for any
situation yeah a central tenet of
maneuver warfare is attacking the
enemy's ability to make decisions and
shift the mental aspects of warfare to
the Marines advantage in short Marines
develop an intellectual edge by learning
cognitive skills and competencies that
enable them to move through the observe
orient decide and act cycle often
referred to as the you loop more quickly
and effectively than the enemy but
warfighter who recognizes what is
happening adapts the situation and makes
and then makes effective decisions in
the shortest amount of time will
typically have an advantage the OODA
loop decision-making cycle is even more
important in preparation for future
conflicts because as new technologies
emerge the rate of change will continue
to increase
therefore Marines must continuously
improve their knowledge and skills by
leveraging technology but never depend
upon technology alone as the solution
we're back to Colonel Boyd
Marines should observe their environment
to recognize key cues synthesize these
cues to orient and quickly make sense of
the information in order to decide and
act and then Marines will start the
cycle again as they observe the effects
of their actions so you ever play chess
yeah are you good no but I can play okay
so so you think you can take me no okay
check you probably could I don't know if
I would just play or I don't play chess
okay so I know how to play but I don't
play it but I understand I understand
the game so one thing that's interesting
about the game is and there's a great
documentary about the current world
champion in chess and a Frida's last
name is first name is Magnus yeah I
watched it I know it's talking yeah so
what's cool is and what I learned from
watching that documentary is that when
you're a good chess player you're seeing
patterns you're just seeing chunks of
the board and you can take all those
pieces that are there and you understand
the whole thing and then the better you
are the more chunks you understand the
more you understand how they're gonna
play out and it's the same thing now
when you take that and you look at you
know if you look at jujitsu like I see
where your arm is and I know what that
indicates the three possibilities that
you have and one of those possibilities
isn't really a possibility because you
also have your leg over here so that
means two Possible's and so you can see
these chunks you can see things and you
can you can react to it and then as you
get good at reacting to seeing these
chunks and get good at reacting to
pattern recognition what makes it so
what happens is you see pattern you get
pattern recognition and what makes it
easy isn't that you it's not that I see
a pattern and I see a pattern I see a
pattern I know what to do and I know
what to do one or two that's easy that's
like level one that's your white belt
thought process but what makes it easy
when you're operating a high level is
you see the chunks you see the patterns
that you've that you recognize and you
know what to do but then you see a small
outlier
and you're able to recognize it if you
didn't know those patterns you wouldn't
recognize that outlier at all as soon as
you see that outliner because all those
chunks those other pieces are where they
are you go outlier I understand how that
outlier fits into this whole picture and
I can solve that problem
I can solve it a thousand times faster
then someone that has to take all the
different chunks and all these different
things and putting together so when
we're training Marines or training
humans what we're trying to get good at
is that whole process right there and
when I see something I go oh this is
what's happening okay I see that yep I'm
gonna do this and I see that madea's oh
here out of the five things that took me
no fault whatsoever I could solve those
without even thinking I know what to do
and then there's this one outlier thing
that I seen like a hoe that's the weight
that's different and if I had to deal if
I had to deal with each of those five
chunks in an individual basis and solve
each one of those problems
I wouldn't even notice that outlier I
wouldn't even see it but when I see
itwhen I recognize everything and I
pattern recognition on five things or
four out of five things that one thing
that I don't recognize I can focus my
efforts on it and I can get it solved
and that's what you're trying to change
trained leaders to do is recognize even
you know even when we talk about dealing
with people right dealing with you know
you're in a leadership position here's
the nine different types of you know if
you and I if I say I gotta go talk to
this guy who's you know hey you know has
a bad temper and hit you and I'll roll
plan and there's eight things that will
cover and I'll be like you up if he does
this you do that if he does that I'll do
that and when I walk in and confront you
about this or talk to you about this
seven of those things that you throw at
me I'm already ready for it and that
means when you hit me with the one that
I didn't expect it's cool because I can
just go okay I see what he's I see I see
where he is
I see what's happening I have the other
parts handle and I can just focus on
this one little thing right now which is
I see what's happening he's really
committed to this part of his plan okay
cool hey you know what I think that one
part of your plan I think that's
actually one of one of the better plans
I've seen and all of a sudden I solved
that thing which if I went in that room
without recognizing the other patterns I
never would have even seen that outlier
yeah that's a really complex thing that
I just tried to explain how did I do
echo
I do it pretty good not that maybe this
is just a maybe add to it but yeah so
you have the eight scenarios and you
know nine scenarios out of the ten or
whatever that you know the one that you
don't necessarily know if you're
thorough with the nine that you know you
know why you have the solutions like the
solutions are the solutions for these
nine that you do know for reasons right
so you know about all those reasons so
when that tenth one comes that you don't
know the solution but you know all the
reasoning behind the other solutions and
you apply those are that reasoning yes
zooom saying so yes I dig it you're
you're talking about running they
reference as a loop which they do the
Marine Corps uses I mean Boyd basically
drove maneuver war if the Marine Corps
with that concept but you're really
talking about running a loop with all
these different loops at the same time
and the real key is to find the one
where the point of friction really is
and that's why if you and I are playing
this linear game just you against me and
this one thing it doesn't really make a
difference but if I'm running seven or
eight and I recognize that this is the
one where the friction really is and you
don't even you have no clues even there
I'm not even worried about the other
ones now I need to keep up with those
things I can't ignore them but I'm gonna
solve this thing and I'll be making
decisions to maneuver this place where I
want it and you won't even know that
it's happening that's how come when you
said are you gonna beat me at chess I'm
like well if you actually know how to
play chess I don't I'm not gonna beat
you because I'm actually sort of still
just playing checkers yeah you are off
you're solving this other problem that
I'm not even paying attention to and you
might have eight nine ten multiple hooda
loops at the same time of all these
different things but only you have to
throw out the one that matters and if I
don't know what you're doing I'm not
even competing with you yeah I'm losing
even know it yeah and and as I was
talking about with you the other day
yeah I'm running who two loops on top
I'm running a loops we do two loops
inside it yeah so it's like there's
through four or five things that are
going on but there's a bigger thing
that's going on outside of that we got
Huda loops going on inside of Buddha
loops and and nut you can't do none of
these things you can't deal with the
seven who loops going on at the same
time and identify the other one you
can't do two loops within loops if you
get caught up in those loops yourself
you've got to be able to detach that
back
and the more that you trained to do that
the easier it becomes to recognize these
things these outliers and you're able to
focus your mind where you need to focus
it and make decisions properly yep
and sometimes those cues are are
miniscule and subtle and you can almost
unidentifiable but if you've done it
enough oh yeah if you have done it a lot
and the more you do it these things
these little tiny unnoticeable things
start to just look like just giant red
flashes so easy to see you know there's
the flank coming at me yep yeah I
remembered Top Gun you do a lot of one
against one a lot of pfm it kind of
feels somewhat two-dimensional linear it
kind of is but there's a million little
cues that takes a lot of experience and
I remember fighting with someone and and
probably halfway through the fight and
debriefing kind of recognizing this is
the place here where I knew that these
other things were no longer gonna happen
and this would happen I maneuvered here
that's how I got behind you and killed
you and say how did you how did you know
this was gonna happen here when I was
you know five minutes previous in the
chessboard I'm like well looking across
the horizon your leading edge flaps are
kind of dug in a little bit lower than
normal which means you were at least
between I don't know 220 and 240 knots
let's go to your tape and it's 237 knots
and he's like how and like look I'm not
smarter than you but I have seen that
and I've looked for that and I noticed
you're you're three degrees above the
horizon which means you're going a
little bit slower which means you don't
have these options anymore I don't have
to worry about you going upward so I'm
making these decisions based on what and
he doesn't even know those things are
happening and it's like you said those
cues but after a while those cues become
so easy to see yeah there's four or five
hooda loops that are going you could you
can throw them all throw for from away
the fifth one you go oh yeah here's
where he's going max got it yep and I'm
gonna be right here waiting for him
totally good luck I'm gonna start
maneuvering on this chessboard you don't
know what's happening and then you're
gonna make your moon-like I'm already
set up ticking away therefore you're
totally
next through progressive learning and
experience Marines at all levels develop
a bias for action enabled by adaptive
rapid decision making the more Marines
learn and exercise this bias for action
the better it becomes once again the
more Marines learn and exercise this
bias for action the better becomes and
this is something that you know on EF
online last week a guy said hey I'm not
an aggressive leader you know what you
know what do I do I'm not an aggressive
leader how do i how do I get better and
I said well first of all and I let out
the whole thing like when you're talking
to and we ended up covering a similar
question on the podcast which is like
hey aggressive doesn't mean Loudoun in
your face
it doesn't mean getting crazy aggressive
means you are making you're taking
action it's aggressively pursuing action
and one of the things that I use is
people say how can I train someone to be
more aggressive it's real easy you put
them in situations where if they're not
aggressive they die or whatever
metaphorical world you live in
hey if you don't call the client the
clients gonna blow up and you're gonna
lose the deal if you don't solve this
this problem with your electrical system
that electoral system is gonna fail and
it's gonna be a disaster so what you
learn to do is go okay I'm not a hundred
percent sure what to do but I'm gonna do
something right now and make something
happen and you must I mean this was
super easy for me because I would put in
an element out in the field there's a
you know there's there's some seals
assaulting a target and as they're
assaulting the target you know they'll
have a single shooter an outlying
building and they learn real quick if
they do nothing cool that guy's gonna
get his friends and he's gonna kick
their ass and if they do something
aggressive they'll get that problem
solved before it even really becomes a
problem so you can learn a bias for
action and that's how you learn and by
the way sometimes you you you do
something aggressive and it doesn't work
out the way you want it to you're
playing you're playing a little bit
there's a gambling right there's a
there's a there's an odds
there's odds to be played and we covered
this couple podcast ago you're playing
the odds right and odds are seven out of
10 times your aggressive move is going
to be the right move
three out of ten times maybe it wasn't
the best move but you you gotta play the
odds and that's also why we do it or if
decision making because just because I'm
doing something aggressive doesn't mean
that I go all-in and sacrifice
everything else no I make a small move
in the direction that I think is right
aggressively and then I'll eat read my
feedback loop off of that continuing
although war games or training exercises
approximate the conditions of war
Marines cannot fully replicate the
dangers complexities emotions and
friction of actual combat Marines
experience a variety of training
situations that approximate combat
situations so that learned experiences
can be remembered and applied during the
stresses and friction of combat through
both direct and indirect experiences
Marines develop a realistic appreciation
for what is possible in combat and what
is not so one of the things that I used
to tell guys one of the failings of
training for me when I was training when
I was running training was we at
paintball we had laser guns to simulate
one thing that I could not simulate is
fear of death because I couldn't do it
with my trade at role players because
they'd be like hey we're gonna die we're
gonna get something and that's a little
bit more realistic because you could say
hey these are jihadis and they don't
care if they die cool but the seals to
say like you know there's a Down man in
the middle of the street and it in one
second there's four seals running out to
save them when those rounds are hitting
it's gonna take a moment yeah you know
it's gonna take some cover fire it's
gonna take a moment so that's the one
thing I would have a hard time
simulating is hey you're gonna be afraid
any even if you're not afraid two of the
guys three of the guys that are with you
are gonna be afraid are not gonna want
to step into that alleyway they're not
gonna step away into the street or
whatever and so you got to calculate for
that so I would try and get people to
behave as if you know you do this you
you die when I read this I was thinking
of a story you've told me you tell the
story a lot is a story about stoner in
his first combat mission and you go
through the story what happens in the
guy after it I think there's
the the battalion commander the hues of
workin he's like man he was a mid team
leaders a mid team major yeah he's a
major team which by the way just real
quick mid team that meant he had been
you know in in Ramadi for five months
getting in gunfights
but yeah totally and just the point
where he's like hey man obviously you've
been in a ton of these experiences and
kind of you're like actually Seth was
like no that's my first time but even
like I was even look at the little
things like the training approximates
the combat situations they were smart
enough to not say replicates or is exact
it's not the same but it's just enough
to get you to be prepared for what
you're gonna see and actually if you do
it well you can't make it perfect but if
you do it well that's exactly how people
respond in that most chaotic thing which
was exactly what happened to stone yep
yeah it's and I would have guys all the
time come back and say oh yeah thanks
for the training because it was as good
as it gets
totally fast-forward a little bit
Marines need to develop the memory
skills because Marines as human beings
increasingly tend to digitally store and
search for information rather than
committing information to short-term or
long-term memory Marines cannot always
rely on technologies are on being able
to digitally search for information
during combat due to many reasons such
as time constraints lack of networked
NASA Act access or the need to minimize
electronic signatures therefore means
that all levels need to train their
minds to memorize and recall important
information to reflect upon that
knowledge to develop understanding and
frequently exercise these skills through
training so that information can be
recalled instinctively during combat and
I forgot to mention that yes I am
skipping forward through some of this
information be but you know it's just
because we're not going to we're going
to try not to do a 17 hour podcast on
this one manual I was wondering how are
you gonna not read the whole pub I was
wondering it too especially in the
opening when you're just going okay this
whole thing totally this whole thing is
good next section key principles of
learning the first learning principle is
know yourself and seek self-improvement
a Marines mindset values ethics and
experience
as impact his or her learning decisions
and actions once again
sorry Sam Harris we do have free will or
at least Marines on the battlefield Sam
Harris have free will to make decisions
and take actions based on the impact of
their learning based on their mindset
based on their values based on their
ethics based on their experiences
fast-forward a little bit when Marines
are aware of how perspectives and
experiences shape their thinking they
can better identify assumptions biases
and other factors that influence
learning previous experiences are
valuable for many reasons such as
providing personalized references to
integrate new knowledge skills and
experience into memory Marines learn and
fight effectively despite friction which
has been described as the force in war
that makes the apparently easy so
difficult learning is not always easy a
lack of self-awareness emotional
regulation humility time management or
biases can cause friction that makes
learning more difficult yeah check it
out if you're not self-aware
if you can't regulate your emotions if
you're not humble if you don't have good
time management or if you have biases
you're gonna it's gonna be hard to learn
which are all natural things by the way
which are all natural things which are
all things that we kind of every by
natural I assume you mean like that's
where we tend yes sir
we tend to lack self-awareness we tend
to not be able to control our emotions
we tend to lack humility we tend not to
be able to do time management we tend to
have biases big time yeah I think you
are correct deckle journals Marines
overcome this friction and seek
self-improvement by better understanding
themselves particularly how our values
ethics and perspectives influence
learning and now I think it's important
to remember that we're talking about
learning in that context right there I'm
talking about hey what I learned from
this class or this training it's what am
i learning on the battlefield what am i
seeing and how are my biases negatively
impacting how I'm able to take on this
new information and adapt to it
that's what happens you know you have
this idea in your head of how things
should be and therefore when the enemy
does something don't expect you you you
you don't accept it you act like it
happened a different way they couldn't
they just got lucky you make excuses for
yourself you make excuses for the enemy
they got lucky they can't do that again
those are your biases preventing you
from learning I mean we must have we did
that like crazy in Iraq we as a country
yeah right oh they they can't be this
can't be an organised campaign you know
so just there's just some rabble rousers
out there but we we just wouldn't accept
it this isn't an insurgent these are
just some out pockets outlying of some
disgruntled folks around here and fast
forward a year and a half two years we
got a full-fledged insurgency on our
hands
what's a rabble rouser something that
just causes problems second principle
the second learning principle is be
ready and willing to learn you wouldn't
think you'd have to say that yeah but
you do without a doubt even that first
one I've know yourself and seek
self-improvement it seems like that
would be a natural natural tendency to
do that it's actually not your your ego
at some point gives like you don't need
to keep learning you don't need to get
better you don't need to improve and the
reason that's in there is that not only
is it natural like you were saying that
is an overwhelmingly powerful force your
own ego telling you bro you've got this
thing figured out yeah you don't know
yourself yeah yeah who knows me better
than myself who's over there quote
sunsoo go Charles no well yeah I'm just
saying you said in there so you ever
seen yourself well you're probably
different but us normal people we
sometimes will see ourselves on camera
or hear our own voice on in a recording
and be like oh my gosh I can't believe I
sound like that meanwhile you know who
listens to your voice 100% of the time
you yet you still don't really know
yourself because when you see it kind of
you know detached from you doing it in
the moment it seems different for some
reason
and that weird so we kind of don't know
ourselves I think yeah I would say
there's very few people that when they
hear themselves they go yep that's what
I sound like yeah especially at first
after a while you know yeah you get used
to it or whatever but doesn't at the end
of the day that's a common thing I think
for people where they either see
themself and or they hear themselves and
they're like they're like oh and they're
for some reason moved by it in one way
or another you know like they haven't
been with themself their whole life kind
of thing you know like it's some kind of
weird surprise or something like that
so it's kind of like no you don't really
know yourself I think you for the most
part anyway like you experience little
little slivers of yourself while you're
behaving and then you kind of paint your
own picture like oh I just said that I
must have sounded real cool saying that
I mean while you hear it played back
you're like dang it is oh yeah those are
those are valid you know what's
interesting about this section right
here so I start off by saying now you
know this is this is what's good about
the ring course you know this thickened
lance-corporal can read this and and
Gunny sergeant can read this and a
colonel can read this and they all can
like understand it here's what's
interesting about this this section
right here believe it or not in my
humble opinion is actually aimed at the
colonel because the lance corporals like
a bruh I'm here to learn em I got my
mind is wide open it's the colonel and
the Gunny or the master guns that's like
I already got this or already of this
depending if it's the gun or the car
right yeah because the minute that you
think you know everything is the minute
that you are not ready and willing to
learn and that's when you're going
backwards so this section right here
they actually aimed this section
point-blank at this the senior people
that think they know everything cuz
those those young kids man they're ready
to learn they they're not sitting there
going hard to know this I mean it's like
a new guy in a seal platoon that guys
that kids ready to learn but once you're
a senior enlisted guy or you're a more
senior officer all of a sudden you know
anything you know everything
Marines have the professional
responsibility to learn throughout their
careers and should always seek
opportunities to learn Marines must take
an active role in learning be
intellectually curious and look for new
ways to adapt when they have learned to
other to adapt what they learned to
other relevant situations there are many
factors that indicate a person's
willingness and readiness to learn such
as physical behavioral societal
emotional and cognitive skills
additionally humility courage integrity
perseverance motivation and discipline
are other key qualities that affect the
learning readiness what's the number-one
humility interesting courage is number
two why is that because what kind of
person just says you know I already got
this right or they're they don't have
the courage to raise their hand that's
what I should have said the person that
humph is not humble says you know I
already got this the person that lacks
courage won't go hey you know what hey
boss you know what I don't I don't
really understand this can you can you
can you tell me this again that takes
courage you're in a group of people
raise your hand man when I was going to
college and I was a twenty whatever year
old man going to college with a bunch of
18 year olds I had I had ponder and
stuff more courage from the classroom
I'd be like professor I don't understand
that can you go over that again yeah and
it made me so much do so much better
because you know that guarantee there's
kids in the back of class they don't
understand something they're not gonna
say anything look stupid I didn't care
yeah so you have that courage integrity
perseverance motivation and guess a plan
starts with humility ends with
discipline I like this bucket Marines
increase their learning readiness by
having courage perseverance and
discipline to continuously seek new
professional knowledge skills and
experiences a Marines learning can be
facilitated by developing an awareness
and understanding of one's own fall
processes Marine sharpen their intellect
by studying how to think better than
applying these skills to improve as
learners leaders and decision makers the
third principle is to understand why you
are learning and this is what's key what
you can take away from this hey look
apply this to yourself for sure apply it
to your kids apply it to your students
apply it to the people that you work
with you want to make sure everyone
understands why they're learning
especially the kids like yeah for you
absolutely apply it but as an
instructor you can you can reverse
engineer this as an instructor and you
lead with why something is important to
know and that will help people open
their brains when Marines understand why
they are learning concepts and skills
they better understand the importance of
learning to the mission and are more
motivated to learn by understanding the
context of learning Marines are better
able to apply concepts and skills to new
situations increasing their competence
and adaptability unknowns uncertainty
and disorder will never be eliminated in
battle information may be unclear
misinterpreted influenced by the enemy
or communication systems may fail when
Marines understand why they are learning
it enables them to focus on learning of
the known and adapting to the familiar
then adapting to the unfamiliar more
quickly and effectively than the enemy
that's the outlier thing we just talked
about yeah I see all the things that
you're doing I see the nine pattern
recognitions there's the one outlier I'm
on it out learning the enemy therefore
is key to fighting enemy that's a big
deal out learning the enemy is the key
to out finding not not the brute force
not getting bigger equipment or stronger
things it's out learning him that's how
you're gonna win mm-hmm yeah and when
you start to look at learning as a skill
that's required for battle you start to
look at it different yes totally and
then you could start breaking down well
how am I gonna go about learning right
what am i paying attention to how do I
assess things that I'm hearing how do I
assemble all that knowledge together
there's a lot that goes into it dude
there's a ton and if and I wasn't around
when somebody decided we need to put a
doctor pub around learning for the
Marine Corps but a it's a really good
idea and it probably came from someone
who was like me that as a second
lieutenant who had a pile of things that
I was supposed to learn when I got to
the basic school and they gave me all
these same pubs warfighting tactics
strategy and learning to me was I'm
gonna read this to and find the answers
in these books so I can take the test
pass and be really good and I'm gonna
learn what the answers are which is
totally wrong totally different and the
sooner the force that any organization
figures out how to crack the code and
getting people to actually want to do
this for their own self-interest the
better and I'm sure that that's a driver
behind this is a generation of people
going I'm learning what the answers are
and that is not learning that is not
that is not an effective way to do and
that's part of the reason why madness is
so credible because the things he talked
about more than anything he doesn't talk
about combat nearly as much as he talks
about all the preparation he did and all
the things that he read and that's what
people figured out about Madison's what
made him brilliant was how much he he
read and studied and each time he read
and studied he got a little bit of
pattern recognition yeah understood
things better got a little smarter got a
little bit smarter learned yes second
lieutenant Burke didn't learn nearly as
much as he should have yeah you know and
that's one of the things you know on the
thread podcast a you know I talked about
the fact that everything's connected and
when things aren't when you don't make
the connections between things it'd be
like if you started taking jujitsu and
people are like okay this is the arm
lock you're gonna learn that in the arm
locker room and then you go into another
room with another instructor and they
teach you the triangle then you go to
another room with another instructor and
they teach you this sweep all those
things by themselves they're not
meaningless but they have little value
very low value comparatively speaking so
that was the original idea of the thread
podcast was listen people don't connect
everything and everything's connected
Connect things the fourth learning
principle is to provide and receive
constructive feedback one cannot learn
without feedback it is critical to
learning and develop being a
adaptability there are two sources of
feedback intrinsic sources ie internal
and extra neck force sources ie external
for example a Marines own perception
that he or she jerked the trigger when
shooting a rifle then adjusting the
trigger fall on the next shot would be
an example of intrinsic feedback
in this same example extrinsic feedback
would be a marksmanship instructor
marksmanship instructor identifying
their error in them to the Marine then
demonstrating the proper trigger pull
both intrinsic and extrinsic feedback
are important for learning and
developing a adaptability adaptability
is the quality of being able to adjust
to new conditions Marines develop
adaptability when they examine a
situation recognize what is happening
and adjust their response to the new
conditions the process of learning is
itself a form of adaptive behavior and
is essential element of combat
effectiveness check the final principle
is that learning is purpose driven to
develop professional competence learning
has specific goals and measurable
objectives to gauge progress toward
developing competencies Marine learning
is team oriented so the Marine so that
Marines develop the skills and
connections to fight collectively
additionally Marine study history and
world events to be more prepared to
respond to new challenges such as the
increase in globalization and
competition for resources effective war
fighters adapt to fluid changes in
circumstances in order to deal with
complex problems and to proactively
shape events for advantage marine
sometimes conceptualize the enemy and/or
adversary as a single person or group of
people but should be viewed as a complex
complex system so obviously marine study
history and world events and that that's
just you know one of the most awesome
things that happens to me when I travel
and meet Marines around the country and
around the world is a lot of Marines
listen to this podcast so that they have
a better understanding of war in context
of history and so by listening there
they're fulfilling you know at least in
some part fulfilling this and what's
really cool is when someone sends me you
know
a picture of 12 books from the podcast
that they ordered in red and now they
have an even more in-depth knowledge of
things there's a there's a lot in here
man this idea of adapting the fluid
changes and circumstances in order to
deal with complex problems and
proactively shape events for an
advantage that's the core of every
question we've been asked at echelon
firm for the last month in this complex
fluid environment that nobody
anticipated and nobody expected to
happen and what are they going to do to
proactively shape the outcome rather
than just be a victim of it on how this
thing plays out what do I need to do to
shape the outcome what do I need to take
control over and if you don't have a
long history of learning how to deal
with these type of settings you're gonna
have a really hard time and it's nice to
bring that word shape in as opposed to
what can I do to control the outcome
because that's why you can't control the
outcome the outcome is gonna come
how can you shape it teachers manage
next section the human dimension and
science of learning conflict is a human
phenomenon understanding human nature
helps Marines to understand conflict
Marines prepare for the complexities of
each conflict by studying social
economic political cultural
environmental interpersonal and
intrapersonal factors you got to know
human beings how many times have I said
that on this podcast echo Charles I want
a number 86 701 these factors often
exert a greater influence on this
character and outcome of war then do
factors such as the size of the enemy
formations and their equipment so all
these things human nature has a bigger
influence often times then besides the
enemy formations or their equipment
we're talking about just human nature
and and that's why leadership is always
the most important thing leadership is a
human endeavor you could have the best
and the most equipment in the world and
if you have bad leadership if you don't
understand your people you
going to lose you're going to lose
against the person who is better led and
better understands the human component
that you're dealing with that's really
the comment you made earlier like those
are human things yeah I even wrote that
down leadership is also a human endeavor
Marines go as I even wrote down this is
huge and underline that Marines learn as
much as possible about the different
human factors cultures perspectives and
ideas that impact operations developing
self-awareness of the personal factors
that can detract from learning such as
hubris ego bias enables Marines to
overcome friction Marines strive to view
situations and information objectively
and unemotionally provide candid
feedback to each other and learn to
overcome or mitigate factors that
negatively impact preparedness yes yes
yes and yes ego bias bring us down
marine strive to view situations and
information objectively and
unemotionally and provide candid
feedback to each other and learn to
overcome or mitigate factors that
negatively impact preparedness reason
I'm rehashing that one is because
sometimes people utilize the candid
feedback thing but they forget about ego
and hubris of the other person so when
may you I'm just gonna give you some
candid feedback there uh echo Charles
when I forget about is that you have an
ego and so by giving you this candid
feedback that you're not really prepared
to receive you're gonna get defensive
the whole nine yards you're not gonna
make any changes whereas if I can find a
way to use maneuver warfare around that
ego and provide you with feedback that
somehow comes from your own brain
because the seeds been planted by me
it's gonna be better off throw a little
bone to the Marine Corps on that one
just a little just take your thought
process
a little bit further on that one yes
Dave a little bit more just can we go a
little bit can we apply what we're
talking about just a little bit more and
be a little bit a little bit better
candid feedback is awesome when there is
this level of relationships and an ego
egos have been put in check it works and
then we strive for that it's hard to
achieve it's hard to achieve
yeah unemotional unemotional candid
feedback because how many people do you
know really are geared to absorb candid
feedback in an unemotional manner
especially after something like
preparation for yeah
what I wrote about that in leadership
strategy and tactics like I tried to I
try to help the person on the receiving
end right I'm like listen when you when
somebody gives you criticism even if
it's coming from some of that you think
has no business giving you any feedback
whatsoever listen to them yeah and
absorb what they say and see if you can
apply it to make yourself better and
that right there that little learning to
do that as a human being if you could
learn to do that as a human being your
life is gonna be a thousand a thousand
times better than it would if you never
get over that hump of hey I don't like
this guy so I'm not gonna listen to what
he has to say
where is someone that's just opened just
says you know what and this is to your
point Dave how many people have I met in
my entire life
that were just oh it hit me with some
more candid feedback so I can just yeah
yeah better yeah do they exist
sure do we get to a point do do
sometimes people you know I have a
relationship with someone or someone
else putting someone through training I
could just tell like I'm saying
something gonna happen oh [__] they're
like hey I got it you know that's a
great point thank you sure if that
happens for sure
doesn't happen all the time it doesn't
happen most of the time does it's a
unemotional candidate feedback yes use
it okay it says marine strive to view
situations and information objectively
and unemotionally provide candid
feedback to each other and learn to
overcome or mitigate factors that
negatively impact preparedness
yeah so I guess overall provide an
except so even the unemotional kind if
you backed up my that so you know how in
a typical situation I don't know typical
what I don't even know what that means
but a situation where you're like hey
candid feedback and the guy kind of
takes it as a as the the the golden pass
to just just basically hit him as hard
as he can like it yeah this method was
straight-up [__] you know like that's
not unemotional that's emotional
feedback right there see I'm saying like
it's on the other side it's on the
negative emotion rather than oh you know
you could have done better you know it's
I mean maybe that's candid but he's
you're right I'm gonna take this one
more one more step for for the next
release of this when we're gonna talk
about this when they revise this when we
talk about candid feedback we also need
to talk about human nature right because
human nature is I bristle it candid
feedback and like I said are there
people that don't and the goal here the
ideal goal is like hey I'm a marine
you're a marine I'm gonna give you some
candid feedback you're gonna take it on
board we're gonna move forward I get it
man I love that I wish that the way the
world works we have to remember human
nature we have to remember that human
nature it provides a level of resistance
against candid feedback I'm sorry I'm
sorry
yeah and they and they they touch on it
they kind of talk about a little bit but
they don't really get to the core of
here's the real barrier you're gonna get
when you're dealing with this now the
good news is that anybody listening to
this podcast is already listening to the
previous podcast and if you're gonna be
an eminently qualified human the way
you're gonna deal with this when they're
talking about viewing feedback
objectively not emotionally then real
scenario is is I'm in charge of this
mission
I built the plan this is all the stuff
and I'm the leader that I come back and
then jakka my instructor comes back and
destroys in what happened gives me
feedback now what he should be able to
do is tell me all these things I'm a go
dude those are all really good points
I'm gonna incorporate all those in the
next mission brief I'm gonna build this
into my play next time we're gonna go
get better but what I do is I come show
up ready for that feedback to defend
what I did because that was my plan how
was the mission commander and I can't be
unemotional and detached but I should be
so if you're listening to the
your job is to take all the feedback you
get even from the people that you cannot
stand in an unemotional and objective
fashion we got a question just last week
what do I do with the perennial
complainer on my team that is constantly
complaining about everything you know
what the answer is
listen to him because it might actually
have some feedback for you the problem
isn't he's a paranoid complainer the
problems that you don't want to hear
them
but the almost exact opposite is true is
when you are providing feedback if you
go in with the assumption that that
person will be just like you and
unemotional and prepared you're also
going to be ineffective that you have to
make the exact opposite approach which
is you're gonna be dealing with nothing
but their ego and you know if it turns
out that I'm debriefing Jocko and he's
totally in the game then then then
that's then we're great no Frank we
represent I don't know five percent or
ten percent of the interactions if
you're lucky that you're gonna get but
over time if you actually take if people
see you as a leader taking other
people's feedback when they appear to be
not credible and not good people to take
feedback from and you're willing to
listen to them you actually can
influence other people doing that takes
time what they don't talk about in here
is when you decide to go do that here's
all the barriers are gonna be in place
with this plan of hey man I'm just gonna
come to the front door Jocko and give
you some some candid feedback he's gonna
take it it's good to go
again look look Marine Corps we get the
ideal I would love I would love if that
was the way the world works
unfortunately we have to deal with human
nature that's we have to deal with just
like you have to deal with it in combat
you have to deal deal with it in a
debrief so be ready for it control what
you can control
learn from it
all right violence and danger will
always be parts of war learning to fight
in dangerous conditions despite fear and
uncertainty is key to war fighting
Marines of all ranks must understand how
the bind body and mind respond to fear
and stress so that they better control
their responses in any situation
including combat Marines learn how to
effectively control stress reactions and
fight dangerous conditions to realistic
training increasing self-awareness
understanding the attributes of war and
increasing mental and physical
resilience for example Marines learn
breathing techniques during marksmanship
training to better control how the
body's nervous system responds to stress
in order to shoot more accurately the
breathing techniques help Marines to
control their heart rate respiration
attention and muscular stress and
muscles under stress which then
increases the accuracy of fire combat
can challenge unit cohesion and present
Marines with a variety of moral ethical
dilemmas Marines develop strong mental
moral spiritual and ethical
understanding because they are as
important as physical skills when
operating in the violence of combat and
it's interesting to and I thought they
were gonna make this connection and
maybe I forgot maybe they make it later
I don't think they do but you and I made
it on the last podcast talking about the
you know the code book the breathing
techniques helped Marines to control
their heart rate respiration attention
muscles under stress and then increase
their accuracy of their fire that's cool
it doesn't only apply to shooting your
rifle it applies to everything that
you're going to do whether you're
dealing with somebody that's combative
and you got to put hands on them whether
you're dealing with your boss that
yelling without you or whether you're
dealing with your six-year-old kid that
just threw a temper tantrum all those
things can come into play the science of
learning encompasses many disciplines
such as neuroscience psychology and
andragogy which is adult learning the
human brain is a constantly reorganizing
system capable of being shaped and
reshaped across an entire lifespan each
new learning event impacts the brain
regardless of the Marines age
or level of experience therefore Marines
should understand that challenging
experiences enhance the brain and better
hone their war fighting capability
science has also identified that
individuals and teams have differences
in the way they learn with varying
sensory preferences for learning
competencies and strengths so that's
something you hear about you know people
learn in different ways but the sentence
before that one challenging experiences
enhance the brain and better hone their
war fighting capability we want to do
things that are hard we need to do
things that are hard adult learning
involves adapting or modifying the prior
relevant information to specific
situation or a problem that the Marine
seeks to resolve you're taking what you
know and applying it to new situations
an effective way that Marines can
accelerate their learning is by
indirectly learning from others through
vicarious experience vicarious
experiences are relevant learning
opportunities that each Marine obtains
by observing reading and studying what
others have experienced there is no
excuse for not learning from others each
Marine must learn how to learn both
independently and collectively in teams
social and interpersonal factors such as
effective communication group cohesion
and trust all influence learning I'm
gonna read that one again social and
interpersonal factors such as effective
communication group cohesion and trust
all influence learning when these
factors are positive they facilitate
learning process facilitate the learning
process and create strong relationships
this is the thing that I've gone over a
bunch of times recently I was like hey
why was I able to like rip apart a young
lieutenant in a debrief it's because he
trusted me and we had we had that the
strong relationship and therefore I can
say I can get candid that's why I caught
myself in the last example I was given
this example where you're gonna come in
and rip apart my debrief and I caught
myself I'm like oh I'm actually going on
the assumption when I
say that that we have such a good
relationship that I realize that what
you're doing is actually trying to help
me as opposed to coming in here and you
know being a tyrant to tear my plan
apart was because of exactly that when
that when when the environment is
positive you can come in and you can rip
that thing to shreds as your knees do to
shreds and all of it is for me to get
better and I look at every single thing
and instead of go man I really wish you
could kind of be nicer when you say that
I don't mean think about that I just
look for the things that you're saying
which actually is a massive time saver
and allows you to be more effective and
more efficient because you're not
worried about those other things but
like you said before the problem with
that is you can't take that for granted
that and that's actually really really
hard to get and a lot of times people be
like hey I'm just trying to help you out
man
I'm just gotta help you here yeah but if
they don't hear you it doesn't matter
you're not effective yeah and the
efficiency thing again I've been talking
about this lately it's like the
efficiency thing of like well look
wouldn't it just be easier if I could
just tell Dave hey Dave here's where you
screwed up and that brief and you did
these three things wrong that's
obviously more efficient and I'm a
matter of fact kind of guy and people
just kind of get on board and like hmm
it would be more efficient if they've
listened to anything I said if he made
it any adjustments but the problem is he
doesn't adjust anything he just puts up
his defenses and so it's efficient in
delivery it's completely inefficient in
absorption totally doesn't work it's not
effective period myrin should actively
seek to understand human and
environmental factors that influence
learning while avoiding thoughts and
behaviors that can negatively affect
learning and cohesion next section
problem solving is a warfighting
capability time spent learning how to
effectively think and solve problems as
time well invested Marines must build
the skills to recognize potential
problems reason and create critically
and think critically reasoning is the
process of thinking about something in a
logical way to form a conclusion or
judgment critical thinking is the
reflective part of that reasoning
critical thinking skills include
inference evaluation interpretation and
explanation developing these skills
enables Marines to understand not only
the information presented
but also its potential implications and
secondary effects and this is one of
those things where when you are when
you're in a leadership position being
able to do this quickly being able to
look at like a problem in a solution and
two or three solutions and being able to
figure out what's gonna happen if I
imply this one this one in this one and
see hey this one will solve it quicker
but I got there enough to deal with this
giant mess that I just created cool I'm
going with option B that's the
difference between you know the white
belt the blue belt leader the blue belt
leader is like okay I see the immediate
solution that I could do but I see that
after effects are worse so I'm going to
plan B yeah through reasoning and
critical thinking Marines explore
question and understand the key factors
affecting the situation which then
enables Marines to do better to develop
better courses of action and again the
more experience you have doing this the
quicker you'll be able to recognize the
patterns of these things and you don't
sitting here think is you know from a
leadership perspective you know you and
I rest the guys in echelon front working
with companies it's a classic example of
well hey we've got this problem here's
how I'm gonna solve it and we all look
at that problem ago okay I I see what
you're saying and I see that that seems
like the direct most direct efficient
way to solve this problem here's the
nine after-effects that are gonna make
this just a complete gut check yeah
because you're not thinking through you
know you well as a white belt leader
you're not seeing this or as an
emotional leader or whatever skipping
ahead a little bit quickly recognizing
and addressing potential problems
enables Marines to better deal with
disruption and respond to changes within
the enemy situation again pattern
recognition responding to those problems
the future battle space will contain
increasingly difficult problems that do
not necessarily have a right answer
therefore Marines skills to observe
objectively reasonably and take decisive
action and then adjust as needed remain
key
the elements of success I mean that's
that's right out of what you talked
about the inner of decision-making and
it's it's not just action it's still
decisive action default aggressive
action but just far enough for you to
figure out and get the feedback of do I
need to keep going doing a maneuver do I
need to back up and the connection of
those two which is decisive action and
then adjust as needed that that is the
connection that is so hard that people
don't don't make sometimes get that
feedback loop going get that fee but I
like the not right answer I remember
hearing about the German war problems or
game problems that the only the only
solution the only solution that would
work are the only options that would
work were were not you know you were
told not to do so hey don't go past this
limit of advance and the only way you're
gonna get out of this is go past that
limit of advance so they're trying to
get they're trying to get the Germans
who are you know have a propensity to
follow rules and so they're trying to
get them hey here's the rule we in order
to get this done you're gonna need to
break this rule what are you gonna do
and but they don't tell them that they
just watch them and they just see him
sit at the limit of advance and get
killed in this scenario the mind as a
weapon the philosophy of maneuver
warfare guides much of what Marines do
and that right there is like let's just
have a podcast about that in fact I
guess we do have a podcast about that
it's this podcast the philosophy of
maneuver warfare guides much of what
Marines do it is their way of thinking
about and preparing for war with the
intended purpose of taking decisive
action against the enemy at the least
cost themselves by the way this is this
is maneuver warfare is the reason I kind
of as a younger leader in the team's the
reason I started to grasp on to it and
understand it was cuz jujitsu cuz what's
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu maneuver warfare
that's all it is its maneuver warfare
its decisive action against the enemy
with the least cost to yourself
that's what jiu-jitsu is Marine study
and apply maneuver warfare in order to
better exploit advantages in multiple
dome
and create rapidly unfolding situations
in the battle that overwhelmed the enemy
maneuver warfare requires that Marines
develop the two OPA by the way also that
what I just read the jujitsu right
create rapidly unfolding in situations
that overwhelm the enemy like um across
that movie yeah oh yeah uh you're caught
maneuver warfare requires that Marines
developed the temperent to preserve
persevere amidst uncertainty and the
mental agility to succeed in fluid and
chaotic situations additionally it
requires being able to understand the
dynamic and complex situation from
multiple perspective perspective to
determine how to exploit an advantage
decentralized execution within the
commander's intent is central to
maneuver warfare this requires that each
Marine understand the situation and
execute actions to support and achieve
that intent so the centralized command
that's why regardless of technology and
equipment Marines are ready to fight and
win therefore it is essential that
Marines develop and maintain an
intellectual edge over any enemy by
developing their minds just as they
would prepare any other weapon system
for battle this intellectual edge must
come from self-discipline study and
deliberate practice as Marines to build
competencies in the profession of arms
as individuals teams units and mag daffs
once again there they're talking about
self discipline they're high they're
kind of highlighting that that that's
what we're talking about
the last part I think it's the last part
of this section continuous learners
developing the mind as a weapon is a
career-long process Marines are
continuous learners they pursue mastery
in the profession of arms recognizing
that the achievement of mastery is a
journey not a destination as adult
learners Marines recognize that they are
responsible for their own learning
outcomes actions and decisions as adult
learners Marines need to know why
content is relevant during both training
and educational activities Marines
perceive learning as a progression of
goals to build competencies not a single
discrete goal hence the analogy of the
armbar in one room the triangle in the
other room no it's all together it's not
a single goal it's all together
therefore Marines benefit most from
information and learning activities
presented in the context of real-life
situations or tasks specific problems to
become better war fighters Marines
continuously gather information and
engage in activities that test their
assumptions develop new knowledge
increased critical thinking and
reasoning and build deeper understanding
instead of simply asking what happened
in a battle Marines should always ask
and seek to better understand why the
events happened and consequently what to
apply for for future situations Marines
must learn about a broad range of topics
and skills through professional reading
experience experience or learning and
deliberate practice Marines must also
approach each event and interaction as a
learning opportunity there is no there
is always something to learn even if
that's something is what not to do in
the future as continuous learners
Marines actively seek apply and share
lessons learn to develop themselves and
other Marines in the profession of arms
and it's it's interesting that in the in
the in the in the eqh book in the
evaluation in the code and we've got
this whole section on improving your
mental capability and and how that's so
important
that's the same thing that the Marines
are saying here conclusion to this first
section they say Marines adapt to every
tool that they have weapons equipment
and their minds to succeed in win in
every clime in place Marines must
develop and demonstrate brilliance in
the basic fundamental skills combined
with the mental agility to adapt to
whatever situation they face I'll say
that again
Marines must develop and demonstrate
brilliance in the basic fundamental
skills combined with the mental agility
to adapt to whatever situation they face
so different from that stereotypical
vision of a Marine that you are just
gonna obey orders to do as you're told
follow orders or people die oh there you
go a few good men speaking of quotes
alright so that wraps up the first
chapter and right now I'm I'm assessing
that we're only gonna make it through
two chapters of this thing so we'll do
one more chapter right now and then
we'll we'll save the next one for it the
next podcast chapter two the culture of
learning starts off with a quote
humility engenders learning because it
beats back the arrogance that puts
blinders on it leaves you open for truce
to reveal themselves you don't stand in
your own way do you know how you can
tell when someone is truly humble I
believe there's one simple test because
they consistently observe and listen
the humble improve because they can
consistently observe and listen the
humble improve they don't assume I know
the way and who's that a quote from
Wynton Marsalis jazz musician trumpet
player interesting right
it's interesting that the United States
Marine Corps took a trumpet jazz playing
musician but his quote on humility is
and and you know it's interesting if we
hadn't written extreme ownership with a
chapter called check your ego and stay
home both like I'd be thinking about
doing that right now there are no
secrets to success as a result of
preparation hard work and learning from
failure that's Colin Powell and thanks
to my reading I have never been caught
flat-footed by any situation never at a
loss for how any problem has been
addressed successfully or unsuccessfully
before it doesn't give me all the
answers but it lights what is often a
dark path ahead and that is general
mattis so ideas and methods can have
more significant impact on war fighting
than weapons systems technology or
organizational structures this is this
speaking of music right the guitar the
the guitar technology that you have the
music school that you went through none
of that can compare to like good ideas
mm-hmm this is an underrated an
underrated thought that I have yeah I
always talk about this I say listen you
can go to a Guitar Center and you can
put a sign up and you can say hey if you
can play these songs you can pick the
most technical songs you know most
underrated analogy you can pick the most
technical songs you'd say if you can
play these songs contact me immediately
and I'll you know I'll give you whatever
I put you on this record and you'll get
hundreds of people that will be a cup I
can play all those songs note for note I
got but all those people can't make a
hit song because they don't have the
creative they don't know the ideas in
their head so they're saying the same
thing here no matter what your guitar is
no matter what technology you have your
ideas can have more sick
forgetting impact on warfighting than
any of those things so the Marine Corps
learning culture fosters the attributes
that every marine needs to pursue such
as adaptability creativity critical
thinking active listening and bias for
action you know there's some there's
some there's some horses that get beat
real hard in this book like they get
beat one of them is bias for action you
gotta remember we're not covering the
whole book right now
I mean I'm skipping chunks and bias
fractions all throughout this book what
did I call that an extreme ownership
default aggressive that's gotta be your
default mode organizational culture the
Marine Corps culture values action again
there's that horse getting another crack
in the jaw responsibility ownership
adaptability and problem-solving
therefore the Marines learning process
and culture develop and exercise these
values oh and I've got a little note
here and this is just like the way that
the Marines roll so listen to this
sentence listen to these two sentences
the Marine Corps culture values action
responsibility adaptability and
problem-solving therefore Marines
learning process processes and culture
develop and exercise these values what's
cool about the Marine Corps is they're
not saying this is what the Marine Corps
should aspire to or this is what the
Marine Corps should do they said there
was the know this is what the Marine
Corps does like it's not even it's not
even a question that's what the Marine
Corps does the Marine Corps is
hierarchical command structure and
process of may at times be perceived as
an obstacle to adaptability and learning
although both are essential for the
proper exercise of command and control
Marines must ensure that they do not set
conditions for unintended negative
effects on learning that could
negatively impact war fighting such as
discouraging Marines initiative feedback
or problem-solving huge huge what
happens when the dichotomy of chain of
command goes too far now we have people
that aren't giving feedback and
so we in need and we need to make sure
it doesn't set those conditions and
again it's I think it's really important
that we think about learning or thinking
about it from the perspective of I'm
learning what the enemy is doing and
it's how I'm gonna defeat the enemy
right it's not like effects not like
negative effect on learning the the
proper technique for cleaning this
weapon it we're talking about learning
how to beat the enemy actively while
that fight is happening skipping ahead a
little bit leaders at all levels are
charged with creating an environment
where continuous learning becomes the
standard leaders serve as positive
examples of a disciplined approach to
learning while also providing their
Marines with constructive feedback
leaders of Marines must dedicate time
and effort to learning and prioritize
mental fitness as much as physical
fitness dang dang you know what one of
my next missions and I guess we're kind
of where we might be on it it's probably
going on right now right
but systemic learning it's again it kind
of goes back to like the the idea of the
thread you should be able to just pick
up and learn things in a cohesive manner
and there's and I get that there's
there's some part of learning things in
a non cohesive manner that forces you to
learn how to put them into a cohesive
manner so there's something to that and
I get it but you should be able to at
least take different subjects and get
them close enough to each other
so that people can easily make those
connections and then maybe you learn how
to spread those things a power apart a
little further so people have to think
even more to get those connections to
come but we make it so hard to learn so
many different subjects that we just
don't connect we don't bring any
cohesion to we don't act we act as if
science history literature to poetry art
we acted as if there are these separate
things
and they're not and the better you
understand each one of those things and
then the better you understand how they
fit together the better you understand
them all and the better you understand
them all the better you understand human
nature and people the better you
understand people the better you can
take all this that all the things that
you deal with in life and put them into
context to do something and shape the
outcome of your life so we need to
prioritize mental fitness and again it's
interesting we wrote the code and and
and the evaluation and the protocols
before this book came out but we made
number one the number one thing you need
to take care of his physical fitness and
number two is mental fitness and the
reason we prioritize them like that is
because if you don't have a body you
don't have a mind I don't think anyone
can argue with that
continuing on integrating learning
activities into physical training events
when Marines are both mentally and
physically challenged encourages deep
learning and facilitates the recall of
lessons learned during combat situations
awesome as part of the learning
experience leaders must foster an
environment that appraoch appropriately
tolerates mistakes errors and challenges
to existing ideas challenging ideas and
making mistakes are part of the learning
process
boom challenging ideas and learning from
and making mistakes are part of the
learning process if you're not
encouraging your subordinates to
challenge your ideas man I love it when
people challenge my ideas and actually I
love it I love it and it's not because I
want to
it's not because I have an opportunity
to like beat them or show them that I
know what's up I like it because I know
I'm gonna learn something I learn from
their challenge their challenge is going
to either break through my position that
I'm going to realize that they're right
or
it's gonna make me patch a hole in my
position that was a vulnerability that
now we can utilize this idea and it's
gonna be stronger challenging ideas in a
respectful and constructive way
contributes to improved learning for
both subordinates and leaders they threw
that they threw that in there thankfully
yeah
yes and in leadership strategy and
tactics I actually tell you how to say
these words correctly because cuz it's
not easy yeah like I like to speak the
truth I'm a straight shooter I'm gonna
come right at you like hey let's just
how I am
so I'm gonna challenge you my boss in a
way that totally undermines the
relationship we have and I just tell you
how screwed up you are not wrong and
you're the problem because you won't
listen to me that's gonna work out
that's not gonna work out that's right
yeah but but I'm the guy whose speech
the true you know boss doesn't want to
hear it people don't like that the boss
just doesn't want any area you can't
handle the truth and then are we going
there leaders should permit ideas to be
challenged in discussion and planning up
to the point where the leader makes the
decision leaders should not
automatically interpret us or a
subordinate challenging an idea or
providing feedback as challenging their
authority to change so they cover it
both know you need to challenge it in a
respectful way and oh by the way you
need to listen to it as if it's not an
attack in order to go well as I said in
them leadership strategy and tactics
people usually think their ideas the
best idea it's kind of the way it is
right totally and you know it you can
actually program yourself to not be that
way and I think I've done a pretty good
job of that actually I usually think
like okay my idea is out there but it's
not necessarily right and I'm I want to
hear other people's ideas you can
totally train to that you could totally
teach yourself to do that and the the
thing that makes that easier over time
is you actually start to win more gets
better like all this was a really big a
big stretch for my ego to start to
tolerate that I'm like oh oh my life is
a hundred times better now than it was
this isn't that hard hey you got
feedback for me dude bring it on yeah
because I bet you my life gets better if
I listen to your feedback
the leaders authority gives him or her
the responsibility to make decisions but
does not mean that the leaders have to
develop all the ideas themselves hmm
leadership strategy and tactics we're by
the way yeah whoever authored this thing
the legit nicely done I appreciate the
appreciate it
subordinates need to be willing to admit
mistakes ask questions and seek
corrective feedback naturally a
subordinate a subordinates willingness
to admit mistakes depends on the
commander's willingness to tolerate them
and what's good about that well I would
you know a little adjustment there our
subordinates willingness to admit
mistakes but also a subordinates
willingness to make mistakes or take
risks that will result in mistakes
depends on the commander's willingness
to tolerate so if you've got a person
that never tolerate any mistakes guess
what no one's gonna do anything for
that's like one of the major criticisms
of like the educating the traditional
educational process like that the the
low tolerance for mistakes so like you
take a quiz it's probably different now
I don't know it's been a long time since
I've been high school but you know when
you take a test or a quiz right say you
have ten questions right you get five of
them wrong that's an F straight up F 50
oh yeah so let's say you have four
quizzes through the course of the year
right if you got a F that it factors
into your final grade no matter if you
got those questions right later or not
you could learn 100% of the material
perfectly but if you got a F on one of
those quizzes your grade might not be
100% same so if you make a mistake even
if you correct the mistake you still get
punished for it assume saying you
couldn't know the correct answer to the
mistake that you made thoroughly
through-and-through you still get
punished I see your point however I
think there's there's other things that
are being trained right like you need to
prepare and study and be ready right
yeah and life doesn't always give you a
second third fourth chance to square
yourself away from your fiddy
yeah but maybe that's what high school
is for maybe not but so I guess you're
arguing understand what what I don't
like about what I just said is that I'm
clearly thinking of it from like well I
said don't not that I don't like what I
just said well you could you could argue
well hey joko so you just want people
learning and studying for grades to get
an A on the grade and that's not that
that's not what I want but there is a
fact of when you go to school you're
learning ok I got to do certain things I
got to do certain things I don't want to
do and I got to do them on time those
are important lessons to learn yeah
about life yeah so what you're you're
unless you want to throw it at me that
school was developed that we could break
children mentally and train them to be
factory workers which is also true that
is one of the criticisms or the reason
for that you know that um you know what
I actually picked up on right now well
it's nothing new really what you just
did
you just responded to that what I just
said with extreme ownership with this
extreme responsibility you know you're I
said this is a major criticism of the
school system and you essentially said
in so many words hey don't blame the
school system you take responsibility
for going to school that's essentially
what you said back to me it's
interesting doesn't make what I said any
less true yeah but you you were like ok
cool you know so what are you gonna do
about it kind of thing you better you
know you better study hard you better
work hard kind of thing seems yeah well
and that's the point that's the point is
what are we trying to do with school
right is it there's a bunch of things
that are going on with school and maybe
if we clarify those things more you
could understand because do you want the
person to learn education right do you
want to get smarter do you want them to
get knowledge yes do you want them to
learn about how to live their life yes
and how do you balance those things
correctly I think not to go too deep
into the school system or nothing like
that but I think that saying that or
feeling that like hey it teaches you to
do this and do this on top of like the
math that I'm that you're learning in
the class I think that's sort of like a
like a Wiggly like not excuse but
it's like they'll just throw that in
it's like part of I guess what it needs
is a clear definition of the mission of
the school right it's very clear
definition the mission of the school and
as a high school kid or whatever you go
on the class in math class what are we
learning in math class you tell me what
do we learn in math class math right I
didn't know we're gonna learn all these
other life lessons that no one says by
the way yeah so it's like okay it's okay
if they clarified the mission and said
hey this isn't just about learning math
this is about learning how to operate
with other people this is learning about
how to learn time management it's one of
the things you're about to learn if you
got told that you probably be okay I get
it if that was part of the curriculum if
you got told that cuz I don't know some
people say that all the time but then
it's like well the rest of the stuff
going on doesn't support what you're
saying I know but whatever but yeah if
that was part of the curriculum only a
hundred percent 100 percent check all
right back to the book Marines will
learn from their mistakes when they
receive constructive corrective feedback
by the way I'll do a little additive to
that statement Marines will not learn
from their mistakes if they are offended
by that constructive corrective feedback
the easiest hedge against the potential
of some of your guys on your team the
Marine Corps anywhere else of having a
problem with that is to actually take
ownership of the mistakes that they make
and I just wrote it down like hey the
ultimate form of tolerating other
people's mistakes which is really what
this is about is you want to let either
people make mistakes because that's
actually good it's learning it's a way
is to take responsibility for that is to
when you're setting up the debrief
rather than go hey corporal willing
here's 37 things you screwed up on this
mission that we did as opposed to hey
let's talk about these things I here's
all the things that happen here here's
all the things that I'm gonna do
differently next time to put you in a
position to be successful so he's
actually not afraid like oh he my boss
me my boss thinks this was his mistake
so even inside this thing this idea of
he said you're tolerating your support
you willingness to tolerate your
subordinates mistakes well anybody
listening this podcast should know that
that actually shouldn't be that hard at
this point because any mistake your
subordinates make is actually who's
whose fault is that really the machine
gunners I know
here's an example a thousand times and
if you want to breed the idea that
making those mistakes is okay there's a
really easy formula to making that
happen and it'll just make them admit it
more and actually come with better
creative solutions to that so they make
them less over time yeah and those are
things a leadership strategy and tactics
I actually wrote down what to say and
what not to say yeah there's a person I
was saying this say that and by the way
one of the reasons that leadership
strategy and tactics that I I went down
that road is because and I was saying
this to a group the other day ah F
online and it's one of these things
where it's here's the deal I've been
doing this for a long time so when I
tell someone hey what you need to do is
take you know go in there and use a
flanking maneuver and set them up with
this and planted an idea in your head
and it'll be good then I I have to be
careful with that
because I'm good at it but I I'm good I
did it when I was at a five with my
particular matter I did it when I was at
you know idea I did it through the
channel I did I've done it a million
times so when some client says hey how
do I handle this person that you know is
uh is complaining right or you know or
or is objecting to the way we're doing
things how do I handle that and I say oh
you could do this I have to say and
listen you need to be tactful when you
do it you need to think about it from
their perspective because sometimes
people hear oh you need to go talk to
him about it okay got it
boom they're rolling into the office
here I need to talk to you about X Y & Z
eath no I didn't mean that
mm-hmm so that's why I like leadership
strategy and tactics like here's how you
actually say this the machine gunner
made a mistake it's not hey echo you
shot outside your field of fire it's hey
echo I don't think I did a good job
explaining what your field of fire is
because you just got Danger Close to the
other squad that's my fault you go there
you go but
next a critical element of learning from
mistakes is embracing an appropriate
level of risk combat is inherently
dangerous and risky however the greatest
mistake in combat could be an
unwillingness to act from a fear of risk
or failure to adapt to the changing
situation so how do you get good at
doing how do you get good at figuring
out what the appropriate level of risk
is it's by making mistakes so if you
don't make mistakes in training when the
time comes in combat and you're
unwilling to even try anything either
out of fear or risk of failure or risk
of getting yelled at or failure to adapt
because you've never done it before like
the the time when you're a squad leader
and you're like looking around and
someone says hey man just go for it you
go for it yeah you like things turn out
maybe they turn out ok maybe they turn
out bad but either way you go ok well I
kind of did it and then you realize you
know what next time I do it I need to do
it a little bit faster but I need to I
need to you know keep the squad more
more and more distance between each
other ok cool you learned a little
something now next time you make an
aggressive mood you've got this little
more dispersion and your squad and
everyone stays alive and it's cool again
this is training so that way by the time
you get in a point in combat where you
need to take some initiative you've done
it before you do not want anyone on your
subordinate team to the first time they
show up have to show any initiative is
in a combat situation or is in a
business meeting or isn't a with a
client that's real that's not the first
time you want to see them take
initiative have them take initiative in
some controlled environments to kick it
off continuing on therefore Marines
should only take reasonable risk during
training and learn to adapt to the
changing situation order which is one
understand all Marines regardless of
position or rank must discuss what led
to mistakes take corrective action and
learn from them you got a debrief
learning from mistakes is key to Marines
learning to act decisively and
effectively while taking prudent risk
which is everything I just said there's
a little section in here which I've been
skipping some of these sections but I'm
gonna hit this one this is here
Battle of Mela would captain John W
Thomason Jr who earned the Navy Cross
during his service with 1st battalion
5th Marines wrote about the 4th Marine
Brigade and he says platoons were formed
as I'm skipping ahead a little Bobby
says platoons were formed in four waves
and he goes into it talking about how
they had maps and how they had a plan
and how they were basically using what
they had learned from the French and so
he says platoons were formed in four
waves the attack formation taught by the
French a formation proved in trench
warfare where there was a short way to
go and you calculated on losing the
first three waves and getting the fourth
one to the objective that's what they
got taught hey you're gonna take four
waves of people the first three they're
all gonna die and then the fourth one
will get through and then it see then he
says after the first engagement the
Marines never used it again it was a
formation that simply accepted
casualties was not adapted for open
warfare and left formations rushing
across open ground incredibly vulnerable
it did not take the Marines long to
learn better and to adapt their tactics
that founded on sound basics learned
during their training
there's anything else on that I knew
you're gonna I knew that you were gonna
talk about that just because of how
often you and I have talked about World
War one and you you hit that over and
over again of all the wars like that's
the one you look at I'm like what what
was going on there what was going on
there from a leadership standpoint and
and honestly my favorite line is after
the first engagement the Marines never
use it again one time they look around
like we're not doing this anymore and
there's kind of a stunning piece on
leadership of what what was everybody
else and they've been doing it for years
when the Marines showed up anyway I just
knew that given how much we've talked
about it that that comment there is
actually really important comment that
they saw it once and then recognize
right away this is wrong and we need to
adapt right now you don't need to do
this five six seven eight ten times to
realize this is a bad bad plan yeah when
I had Dean Ladd on Tarawa right and he
one of the things that he pointed out
was when they were in I think New
Zealand so in between in between islands
storming in the Pacific they were saying
that you know one thing that they
noticed about the Japanese was that the
Japanese didn't adapt they didn't change
anything they would do the same thing
like not only from a not only from a
tactical perspective like oh we're gonna
rush you and if we don't get through
today we're gonna rush you tomorrow from
the same position but not only that but
then and you could see some changes in
the way they defended the islands like
sometimes they'd let the Marines come
ashore and then they've kind of set him
up and sometimes they wouldn't let him
converse so they would make these small
changes but for the most part it was
like we knew what the Japanese were
gonna do and they weren't gonna change
how they were doing things and you know
I was talking a life about it life's
like yeah it's kind of hard to pass on
lessons learned when everyone is dead
which is what was going on with the
Japanese right oh you want to defend
this island cool well you know what
lessons are getting to the next island
none of them because you're all dead you
know we the only people that survive are
fourteen Korean slaves
that's who survives everyone else dies
but the fact that in this situation yeah
and and that is absolutely you know
world war one just sickens me totally
and you know all war is awful but that
war and the leadership in that war to
just Roger that yep Roger that Roger
that Roger that
all right section here areas of
responsibility there are four functional
areas of responsibility in the culture
of learning as shown in the following
figure and there's a little figure here
and it's got some circles that that the
smallest circle is marine meaning the
individual marine and then the
instructor and then the commander or
leader and then the Marine Corps as an
entire institution so it goes like this
the first is it is each individual's
Marines responsibility to progress in
his or own his or her own self education
and build a bias for intelligent action
that's incumbent upon every single
marine is to learn everything that you
can and build a bias for intelligent
action there there's another little went
on that horse I think they're making it
perfectly clear to every marine that
what we want you to do is take action
doing something smart go it moms managed
to tell these these these young fire
team leaders are these tu commanders I'd
like get them together and I'd be like a
to commander imagine if every one of
your fight you have eight fire teams
imagine if you 20 or fire teams was
doing something smart in support of what
you were trying to make happen how hard
would you job be and you'd be like not
hard and I'd be like yeah check I'll be
like fire team leaders do you hear that
this guy wants you to do stuff he wants
you to make something happen
make something happen do us all a favor
and make something happen
I'm tired of watching you guys sit
around trying to form a perimeter being
directed by the task you too commander
himself on how to form the corner for
the love of God would you take up a
security position second with informal
schools instructors should be selected
based upon their potential to become
effective teachers facilitators and
mentors Nikko's into some of that third
leaders at all levels are responsible
for setting the conditions within the
unit for the subordinates professional
military learning and development in the
teams those two are probably opposite
like I don't know if it's opposite but
there's no doubt that in the SEAL Teams
the leader of a platoon like the leader
in the platoon commander of the platoon
chief for the task unit commander and
the task unit senior enlisted advisor
they are them they are way more
responsible than some instructors that
you had anywhere along the way I don't
know if it's I don't know if you could
make that statement about the Marine
Corps I think there's that that
hierarchical component and anything just
sits inside it and and I think a lot of
ways it's sort of this connection of
that's something that's very easily
digestible for the lowest level of
marine to recognize where they fit in
the big picture but the bigger thing
that's happening there is that that that
sort of comes full circle when the
Marine Corps as an institution has this
obligation to facility that that goes
back and affects the individual marine
and that your individual role actually
plays we talk about this all the time
you can play an outsize influence on the
entire organization if you were doing
something that's making you better which
is making your team better and then each
role in leadership has an obligation to
facilitate that and then it comes right
back to me whenever I talk about
training with a company was maybe you
can help me with my own quote but it's
something along the lines of training is
the solemn duty of the leaders inside of
it unit yeah right it's not the
responsibility the trainer it's not the
responsibility the instructors not
responsibly the schoolhouse if you work
for me I'm responsible for making sure
you're trained and I can use those
assets however I see fit but I'm
responsible for it yeah and then finally
the Marine Corps as an institution
demonstrates a focus and commitment to
encouraging career law
learning by continuously refining
learning methods and providing resources
and opportunities for professional
development that's the way the Marine
Corps rules professional expectations
next section Marines are expected to
have initiative self-discipline and
motivation to actively engage in
learning opportunities on their own
wouldn't that be nice if that was a
universal truth about humans right if we
just said humans are expected to have
initiative self discipline and
motivation to actively engage in
learning opportunities on their own
Marines must take ownership of personal
learning by creating specific
professional goals again the the
evaluation that we wrote after assessing
progress Marines may adjust their goals
so that they made this so that they
remain challenging conversely if a
Marine struggles to attain a goal by the
date established the goal may need to be
adjusted to include additional interim
steps feedback or modified timeline
established and clear short mid and long
term goals
enables the Marines to plan a clear path
forward toward professional development
and again this is sort of the reason why
we put together the the code and the
evaluation and the protocols for
everything that just got just written
right there yeah that that paragraph to
me was was huge a highlight of the whole
thing I wrote the word dude and
underlined dude this is ridiculous and
then I wrote down this is why we did
that ranking scale on the I'm really
qualified human being if you're doing
this thing and it's easy guess what you
need to ramp it up because this is no
longer your baseline this is too easy
for you you need to make that more
challenging and if not you got to go
back but you need initiative
self-discipline motivation and ownership
these are all these are all these are
I'm in concurrence with all these I'm
telling you by the way I know I don't
know these guys but I know who these
guys are they love this book I know who
these guys are
skip ahead a little bit learning is also
a process of professional growth
Marines demonstrate motivation of
professionalism by cultivating a growth
mindset individuals with a growth
mindset believe that effort and learning
can change one's qualities leading to
development and success Marines with a
growth mindset understand that they have
control over their individual learning
and that the additional effort pays off
developing in developing the knowledge
and skills to improve
conversely individuals the fixed mindset
believe that their qualities are innate
and are interested in feedback only to
confirm their abilities avoiding
feedback that indicates any perceived
weaknesses avoiding feedback and having
a fixed mindset leads to stagnation
and they wrap this chapter of I mean we
could talk about intrinsic motivation is
driven by perceived internal rewards
that is one is driven to engage in a
behavior because it is satisfying
leaders can cultivate this type of
motivation within Marines by supporting
the growth mindset and individual
Marines can sustain it throughout their
careers in this way the Marine Corps
culture of learning encourages
commanders leaders instructors teams and
individuals to all support intrinsic
motivation for learning and
self-improvement the conclusion is they
say the Marine Corps culture supports
continuous career long learning all
Marines can facilitate learning as
Marines develop in their careers the
responsibility to facilitate learning
also increases marine corps culture
embraces learning as fundamental to
marine readiness to be the first to
fight learning is essential to any
present profession but it is
particularly important to the Marines
profession of arms where the cost of not
learning the cost of not learning are so
steep so that's chapter two or two hours
deep right now in in order to not make a
five hour podcast we will save the next
for the next podcast um so I guess echo
Charles yes since we are you know going
to try to continue to learn continue to
make continuous improvement yes I don't
know if there's any way that anything
that you recommend we learn perhaps sure
that could move us in the right
direction I recommend that we learned
you did too one of the many
recommendations I recommend we stay on
the path this is a real general way of
putting it so we're gonna learn jujitsu
we're gonna stay in shape if not get in
shape we're going to stay functional and
the functional maybe that's a played out
not played out but that's maybe in
ovaries words we're gonna say capable
how about that Dave Burke good I'm good
at functional functional I like capable
I like capable yes if you like capable
why did you say functional and then like
deride it and then now you're calling it
capable I'm putting this what he call a
fine point on it like sharpening it like
functional is like sure yes functional
but let me get more specific capable
okay even though that's pretty general
but to do these things we're gonna need
we're gonna want certain tools okay so
for jujitsu we need a geek rash guard
boom where do we get the key I think we
all know all know BES key in the world
factually origin or jinn main com this
is where you can look at all the stuff
now can we get Giza origin right this
moment on in April 2020 yeah
can we there are some Giza still look
we've done a little we've had to make
some adjustments to what we're doing in
main because America needed certain
items to get through the kovat 19
pandemic so we had to adjust make some
adjustments and start making face
coverings which we are doing at a rapid
pace
probably between five and seven thousand
a day the demand signal is very high and
so we are trying to get America what
they need on those and look they're not
n95 masks but at which we don't have the
capability of making which is why we
weren't making any masks but when the
government and the CDC recommended face
coverings for everyone we started making
face coverings so that's what we're
doing right now as soon as we push
through this and as soon really is the
other manufacturers pick up the slack
because we were able to move very
quickly because we have the entire you
know supply chain right there we have
the skills and capability get the
ability all day you know we got crafts
people up there that can go oh you want
me to sew that cool we can make that
happen
Pete can design it okay done pattern
makers can make the patterns like we can
get it done and and
and that went the original deaf masks
was Friday we're talking about Monday
they're getting produced there's not I
don't think there's any businesses in
the world that could do what origin just
did right there on on I'm gonna say that
again on Friday we're making rash guards
on Monday morning full production of
face coverings you know so hey look but
as soon as just as we pivoted quickly
into that as soon as the as soon as some
other manufacturers get caught up and
people and that and the demand gets met
we'll be right back to doing what we do
and what we do which is make stuff make
apparel so jiu-jitsu apparel rash guard
skis jeans t-shirts boots we'll be right
back on all that stuff so just be on
standby bye yeah again organ mein
dot-com also at origin choco fuel so
this will keep us capable keep us in the
game look after our joints when we're
lifting it's a big deal that's what I'm
saying
so joint we're ferret super krill oil
some antioxidants in there by the way
also mulk additional protein protein
supplementation on the strawberry milk
train yes really yes how much it how
much you have to you do you have one a
day one a day sometimes to on some rare
occasion I will have how many scoops per
per dude AMA I'm a one scoop milk shake
it in a bottle I don't do any other
weird stuff for things but there are
times and I'm not gonna lie to you I've
got a little extra time with my wife
maybe watching TV a little bit on like a
Saturday night more than I have in the
past because of what's going on and I
need a little you know what any
straight-up need dessert okay now we'll
just go back to the mall traffic so
that's my dessert
Saturday nights I've had maybe a little
extra these days but during the day dude
SOP for me is like I will do more and
what discipline in the can is your
preferred flavor discipline in the can
dak savage with that question now the
other two of
but given the choice and I I'm lucky
enough one of those people that I I have
a choice I have options Dakota Meyer
crushed it dec Savage is my thing
how often do you drink one of those one
a day what time usually or just a little
bit after lunch so another thing is I'm
sitting at my desk longer during the day
than I ever really have cuz usually
seven days a week I'm traveling I'm in a
hotel I'm with a client I'm on a plane
and now I'm like up in the morning
worked out get ready and I sit down on
my desk and sometimes I'm sitting
literally sitting at my desk sometimes
like six seven eight hours straight
which I have typically don't do not know
we're on Warren webinars or on podcasts
we are in the game and I'm at my
computer at that chair and these I say
ready to deploy ready to drink cans
there's a DAC savage I get up lunch come
upstairs I don't usually eat a lunch you
don't really have a Camille for lunch I
will have a tax average shortly after
lunchtime what do you feel in your crack
when you once you've digested it what do
you feel I feel good what it really does
for me is if I don't take it I catch
myself like not I catch myself mid early
afternoon want not wanting to not do
what I'm doing
no a little breather I take a look I'm
gonna push away and I'm like no I'm not
I do not time to do that I take that
it's kinda almost like science at this
point I take that little hitter and I'm
in the game and I can push through
whatever that normally would be the hey
why don't you step away and kind of get
some fresh air like yeah I'd love to I
would love to go do that throw the
football with my kids and I try to do
that sometimes but right now dude April
20th 2020 dude we are grinding like we
are grinding at the our desks that's
what we're doing this is the key
yeah notice I I will so I'll get up I'll
have I'll work out I'll left I'll have a
handful of macadamia nuts or something
so now it's you know you know eight
o'clock nine o'clock in the morning so
when I started feeling a little hunger
and you know now when I'm sitting
through my morning calls whatever
talking to clients I'm on the I'm on
the just discipline powder right Jaco
Palmer I'm just gonna I'm just kind of
sipping that's just kind of going
through it's just kind of getting on
step and then like same thing around
lunchtime and usually you know whatever
I'll have a little gap and I'm like okay
I got I got an hour here I got two hours
here and I'll go I'm gonna write you
know I'm writing a book right now so
I'll be like cool but but probably as I
know I see that window approaching same
thing I'll be like well maybe it'd be a
good time to check social media or maybe
it'd be a good time to just turn my
brain off and you can feel that
gravitational pull right so I go oh you
know what crack it open
20 minutes whatever 30 minutes prior
drink it and what's cool is I it just
happens and I get down and start
hammering and then a little I'm like oh
look what just happened because you get
that little little little hitter so we
got that by the way that's discipline go
in a can discipline go or discipline
powder form that was the original yeah
and the Jocko Palmer did I went away
from powder when the cans came out and
when Jocko Palmer came out I went back
to the back yeah I stayed with the
powder for a long time still going
powder all day every day all day every
day may not all day but yes I stopped I
won't have any discipline go in the can
after two o'clock in the afternoon three
o'clock in the afternoon because then
I'll just be i'll be i'll be won't be
able to sleep you know so little
cautious about that also where your kid
milk as well mmm
supplemental dessert like protein that's
really my kid a lot of kids at home all
day right now yes they want a little bit
of that live they want some that tastes
good just get him some of that warrior
kid mold you they think you're hooking
them up you are you know and you are in
many ways from a taste perspective you
can get this stuff at Vitamin Shoppe to
some of the vitamin shops if they're
open they got the full
line up mmm cold war man I talked about
it last time I'm on the cold war on the
cold war train yeah yeah I'm on the cold
war tank cuz I don't know I don't that
what you're in the tank here in Cold War
tank or you got armor the tank of immune
armor system that is that cold war is in
my repertoire that's wake up in the
morning how many you take in the morning
I take two in the morning to at night
what are you doing I take two in the
morning and that's all I take no wonder
if I need a difference more
I don't know you're looking kind of
light and I feels pretty good kind of
exposed that no no Cold War's Cold War's
in the game right now yeah yes so all
these things origin main comm also Chaka
white give you tea on there that's some
good stuff certified organic to need for
the organic folks that's the refreshing
refreshing oh yeah
also check with the store it's called
Jocko store so you go to chuckles store
calm and this is where we can get our
representative apparel when we're
representing on the path while we're
learning is was wincing well we're
improving ourselves seems learning in
quarantine or not see we have a new
shirt it's not that new but we have a
shirt if you want to represent while on
the path in quarantine represent the
quarantine scenario it's what we've been
doing varying levels of approval from
Jocko on this one it's a controversial
shirt is what it is sometimes
decentralized command you know sometimes
it goes too far people start doing
things below the chain of command
they're not running their approval above
the team and things are just happening
unapproved things are happening well
yeah so I'm below the chain yes you're
up the Ches
I run it up yes and what happens you
want to call the story
move on yeah I don't think what you
described is exactly what happened this
was a flat-out denied he's like a
rejection of a plan away we're doing it
anyway yeah I was thinking maybe I
wasn't clear enough apparently
I mean I reread the text I'm like no it
doesn't get any more clear than that
well the in this case the people are the
people essentially what do you call that
when you kind of when you when you you
don't overthrow them but you assume were
saying you know one like the one
government officials like and then the
people are like well you know I don't
know if we accept that well we like it
you know so the people so there's a
rebellion so mutiny run by echo Charles
we moved forward and took smart action
as it were anyway go to Jocko store calm
look for the quarantine sure if you like
it go ahead get it represent represent
while you're doing our social distancing
stopping this whole thing assume saying
cuz really that's what it is you
understand also disappointing comes
freedom on there as well t-shirt that's
pretty cool even dismiss premium flags
in the little box yes
oh yeah that the to warrior kid flags in
the box or your kid card deck of cards
with the little workouts they can do
while they're in quarantine or not we
call that PE yes PE yes education it's a
game too by the way so it's like way
more fun then doing shuttle runs all day
you know we have some hoodies on there
some hats some good stuff anyway go on
there if you like something get
something chuckles door comm also
subscribe to this podcast if you haven't
already very important kinda important
how about this if you want to subscribe
subscribe if you don't want to subscribe
though subscribe more here's what's more
important than that we got up some other
podcast one podcast is called the thread
it is about history and the world and
how everything ties together in the
world that's with Darryl Cooper of
Margar made we got the grounded podcast
which is about jiu-jitsu we got warrior
kid podcast which is for your warrior
kids we also have a warrior kids soap
and Irish Oaks ranch calm young Aiden
building an empire do good work
very good work making soap so that
people can stay clean also YouTube yeah
we do a YouTube channel yeah we do it
which act was quite proud of its good
channel yeah he thinks it's good
as far as channels go he makes videos
where things explode we yeah he makes
videos where things explode sometimes
way too many things explode sometimes
too little sometimes a message could be
perfectly clear but it just seems to be
need to be accented with explosions and
fires sometimes yeah yeah so YouTube
channel also you can watch this whole
podcast on there you see would end and
enhanced videos we also psychological
warfare which is little psychological
hitter if you need it to go into your
ears
we have flipside canvas which is visual
hitters for your eyes flipside canvas
calm we also have some books we got a
book called the code the evaluation and
the protocols that book is available
right now it was on the last podcast
something to guide you through life we
have leadership strategy and tactics we
have way the warrior kid one two and
three we have my key in the dragons we
have discipline equals freedom Field
Manual we have extreme ownership and we
have the dichotomy of leadership check
out any and all of those books they're
all linked by the way they're linked yes
on jaco podcast.com so you can get them
delivered we have echelon front
leadership consultancy which is what
Dave talking about earlier you wanna
know what we're doing all day right now
that's what we're doing we are talking
to our clients 20 30 40 people in a
meeting four people in a meeting one
person in a meeting face to face is it
legal Dave Burke to say I was on a zoom
meeting with a client face to face yes
cuz it's almost more face to face than
when you're face to face you're actually
close
than normally would be where they'd be
30 feet away sitting in some sort of
classroom type scenario right you were
face to face and you were alive so we
have adjusted our methodology at echelon
front where we no longer what we will
eventually go back and work face to face
literally but right now we are finding
that the impact of this online virtual
training is awesome it allows us to have
more interactions closer interactions
more continuous interactions with the
clients so if you need help in your
business aligning your leadership go to
Ashland front comm for details we also
have EF online
speaking of revamping look for a long
time yep online was a static but as
static courses that you'd go on there
and take and they they were static they
were they were interactive and you would
run through scenarios but it was
pre-existing classes so we've blown this
thing wide open
we got live video webinars we got Q&A is
going on we got we got immediate action
drills on there I got leadership primers
just totally revamp that we also change
the whole pricing structure it used to
be like you're gonna pay to take a class
almost like you were going to college
for a semester and you're gonna learn
these things now it's like Oh way
cheaper subscription model or you can
pay it once but it's like boom come in
and you're part of the gang and you're
interacting with me you're interacting
with Dave you're interacting with JP
Lafe Mike's really the whole crew that's
what we're doing we're on there some had
you know Jason Gardner you've heard
Jason garner on the podcast you want to
talk to him cool go to UF online you'll
talk to him you will talk to him as as
Dave just said you'll be five inches
away from his face so that's what we're
doing there EF online comm check that
out we've got the musters the the
orlando monster was cancelled Phoenix
this is our leadership seminar
leadership event Orlando is cancelled we
got Phoenix in September 16th and 17th
we got Dallas December 3rd and 4th check
extreme ownership calm everything that
we've done is
now we were gonna do three now we're
only doing two so they're gonna sell out
even quicker a bunch of people are
already going and moved their their
reservations so if you want to come in
trim ownership calm for that and then
there's EF overwatch where we take
executive leadership from the military
and place them into the civilian sector
and then EF Legion comm these are
frontline leaders that are being placed
into civilian companies if you're and
let me say if you're a vet right now
there's a lot of companies that are out
there hiring go to EF Legion calm and
just enter yourself in there so you get
looked at so people can see that you're
available for employment we've got a
high demand signal from our companies
that we work with that are reaching out
looking for squared away veterans that
understand the principles we talked
about to go to EF Legion comm and enroll
yourself and if you haven't had enough
of my tyrannical utterances or echos
delirious theories or Dave's over
articulated speeches then you can locate
us on the interwebs on Twitter on
Instagram and on dine for easy bomb Dave
is that David R Burke echo is adequate
Charles and I am at Jocko really get to
all you out there in uniform serving now
or if you've ever served in the Army
Navy Air Force or of course the Marine
Corps and we salute you and your service
and a sacrifice for freedom and to the
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers Border Patrol and Secret
Service all you first responders thank
you for your service here at home taking
care of us and to the doctors nurses and
medical personnel that are in the fight
right now battling against disease and
despair thank you
for your brave hearts and your
benevolent hearts and everyone else out
there just remember what the Marine
Corps teaches us that combat is a
combination of fear uncertainty
ambiguity chance horror and friction and
life is much the same continuous
learning is essential because it allows
you to recognize change adapt to it and
make decisions that lead to victory and
failing to learn simply means failing to
win you have to learn so read study get
experience listen and live with a bias
toward action and a mind that is
desperate to learn and then well go out
there and get after it until next time
this is Dave an echo and Jocko out